yeah it makes it this is truly i mean
people say it all the time this divide
and conquer like
it makes it impossible for us to
organize long class lines and really
if we were really talking about power if
that's the conversation we want to have
then we need to be talking about class
definitely i see it it's really
interesting donald trump called for 2000
checks for everybody in the stimulus and
it was the republican party that said no
and it shows you that donald trump
really was an insurgent in the
republican party they did not like what
he
had to offer and then after donald trump
says two thousand dollar checks
joe biden's like fourteen hundred you
know he's like okay so we're
we already gave you the six hundred
we're only going to give you 1400 right
now
but there's something interesting about
trump supporters and left populists
in that i don't think trump supporters
care all that much about billionaires
i i think there's certainly a
conservative argument against
giving the government too much power so
when they talk about wealth taxes right
it's a big thing we see on the left the
bernie sanders crowd
they want a wealth tax you know i used
to i thought about this
are you familiar with the wealth tax um
is that
yang it's bernie sanders and elizabeth
okay yes right the billionaire tax or
something the way it works is
they treat wealth like property and tax
a percentage of your hard wealth you got
to pay for
now i've been very critical of this
because it makes literally no sense
you know jeff bezos for instance i think
his total income from amazon is like 1.3
million dollars per year
his net worth however is like a hundred
and you know 60 billion or whatever or
more at this point because amazon's
you know gain a lot of value because the
pandemic but he can't sell that stock
there's like thresholds and contractual
agreements to where he can finally
liquidate some of those assets
that means what if they implement this
wealth tax they're like bezos will pay
you know three billion dollars a year
but he's worth
you know uh hundred and something
billion and it's like
okay well where does that billion
dollars come from the government doesn't
want stock in amazon and he can't give
it up anyway it's a violation of the
contract the wealth tax makes no sense
he doesn't have the cash to actually pay
for it we hear a lot from the left well
then he should sell his assets i'm like
he legally can't
the wealth text makes no sense at this
point however i'm kind of like
i don't care do it let's see what
happens i don't care about jeff bezos
mackenzie bezos
the only thing where i'm kind of like i
don't know elon musk probably deserves
to have a lot of money because that
guy's building starships
and starlink and other useful things
bezos i don't like soros i don't like
the koch brothers the mercers any one of
these billionaires
i don't like i think they flood money
into politics
they they they subvert the will of the
working class
and i think many trump supporters would
much prefer working-class individuals
have their say-so as opposed to
billionaires
namely george soros who they criticize
all the time but i think we can throw
out all the names of
of tom steyer michael bloomberg
left-wing billionaires right-wing
billionaires
i don't care for any one of these
billionaires i think we do need to have
a reckoning on class issues
the problem is critical race theory
disrupts that
the culture war disrupts that and i
think we have a really strong
opportunity right now with biden office
to actually look at some of these
anti-woke
leftists many socialists and
progressives and be like
which part can we agree on where we
think the billionaires are disrupting
the will of the working class
and kind of like put a stop to that you
know what i mean i think
and we've mentioned this many times
critical race theory was introduced
by powerful interests who knew it could
distract the masses and create a fight
that protects them
right so there's this comic we love to
reference on the show where it's a rich
guy
in his office everything's really pretty
outside is an occupy wall street
protester holding a big sign saying
occupy wall street
and the rich guys on the phone smiling
saying introduce them to identity
politics
and that's really what it feels like
because i was at occupy when this
happened
it went from you know people like luke
rutkowski who was on the show for a
couple months maybe he'll come back
we'll see
luke where are you at luke where yet uh
but he's
he's a center-right libertarian i'm
center-left libertarian
but we agree on these libertarian issues
not liking the elites the authoritarians
and we met at occupy wall street because
these people were down there
until the critical race theorists show
up and started segregating people based
on race
and then you saw people leave and get
angry that was the ultimate slap in the
face and the insult
especially to a lot of younger white
idealistic individuals who are now being
told it was their fault
and they're like yo i'm here at occupy
wall street with you it's like too bad
that happened to me literally i went to
occupy wall street with the constitution
i was going to read it
and they were like hey the news is here
i was like oh good i'll go get on the
news and tell them about the
constitution and how we need to break
the federal reserve up
now there's too many white people have
spoken to the news i just lost my mind i
got on stage
and screamed that i'm not white and then
no one is black or white
these shades don't exist in our
pigmentation or skin color and people
looked at me like dumbfounded
that's another girl that went up was
like i am a black woman who and i was
just like i give up on this i give up i
can't
i can't fight the crowd you have to find
another way
but man it is being silence not the
answer
it was a it was a brilliant attack
vector in my opinion
accusing people who oppose racism of
being the true racists
yeah you know the other problem is the
left right thing um
just the massive fear of of people
on the and i i know these the terms are
probably are meaningless that's kind of
the point but
people are classical liberals right who
are on the left who are like the ground
has now
shifted hold on classical liberal is a
right-wing position
yeah so right so so people confuse the
tradition like the actual classical
liberalism of like john locke
with saying 90s democrat liberal you
know what i mean
so right in the left is another attack
vector thing right doesn't really exist
well
yeah it does yeah it it does words
the colloquialisms of left and right are
confused and meaningless
so there's social liberalism which is
like democrats in the 90s
slightly that's what i mean social
liberalism social liberalism
right so okay this is this is the
liberalism of like martin luther king jr
expanded civil rights civil rights
protections and social programs
but social liberalism is not social
democracy or democratic socialism or
socialism
social liberalism is like center left
meaning
some programs sometimes
and then classical liberalism is like
not that many programs but
yeah that's right classical liberalism
is like smaller government
yeah it's very much like libertarianism
yeah and then social liberalism
is you think we should have the 1964
civil rights act
you think unemployment benefits and a
social safety net is a good thing
my i do i believe all of those things i
just think conservatives have fair
criticisms
of these programs in that they become
bloated congested and corrupt over over
too long
and so we need to reassess i think a
liberal
and conservative is another attack
vector thing dividing us because
i'm both yeah yeah yeah yeah it it
really i know i see
there's so many people i mean like i
know you you all know this well but
i was still a little surprised when i
went on tucker carlson you know i made
my video and i said in my video i'm a
lifelong liberal
and i went on tucker and tucker's like
lifelong liberal jody shaw
how many emails i got um afterwards
saying you know i was with you
but then you went on tucker and and he's
right wing so
i can't i'm not for i'm not with you
anymore even though my message
had not changed at all and so that's
when i
i realized this is a big problem is that
people who otherwise
um would be able to see this stuff in
their midst the crc stuff and be like
well this
is wrong but they're still kind of
confused if they're they're so scared of
if they go off par the script of being
associated
with the right and that fear is so big i
mean there's like
it's like an epithet to be called right
wing to to some lib
to some liberals identity politics to
say i am
a fill in the blank is identity politics
to say i am
center is identity politics i am left
identity i am a democrat identity
this identity crap yes we need to
we need to drop it there's a quote from
andrew
breitbart that uh i think you should
hear i wonder what your opinion is on
andrew breitbart
i don't know yes he's a he breitbart
magazine right uh website he he passed
some years ago
but he said walk toward the fire don't
worry about what they call you
all those things are set against you
because they want to stop you in your
tracks
but if you keep going you're sending a
message to people who are rooting for
you who are agreeing with you
the message is that they can do it too
love it there was another quote which
was
either derivative of this or spawned
from it where
that you know i've often misattributed
to breitbart but similar walk towards
the fire
people think that once you get to the
fire you'll be burned but in reality
you'll pass through
and see freedom on the other side yeah
i've heard that quote before
that's true i think that i've
experienced that so these people
are scared and there's a lot of there's
a lot of like uh
you know moderate leftist personalities
and
i should say leftists like traditional
and classical liberal types
that are absolutely terrified of finding
themselves
in a in league with conservatives but if
you live that way
then you're living on your knees so i
don't care i i i had a uh
there's probably some hit piece coming
out against uh about me soon probably
and i get this thing where they're like
tim poole has hosted alex jones and
enrique tario
and these people they like to do this
thing where they're like here's a photo
of tim poole sitting down
at a bar with the alt-right and i'm like
uh-huh
and i don't care i really don't i've
you know they they come at me and
they're like can you explain this photo
tim
yeah i talk to people that that's about
it i'll talk to whatever i feel like
talking about
i don't care about what they call me i
don't care about what they think
i literally do not care i just don't
and and if you do you are being held
back
because they have no control over you
they don't
now look i get it i think there's a lot
of people who are like i don't want to
lose my job i'm comfortable
but if you think keeping your head down
will keep you safe you are wrong
they will come for you eventually i mean
you kind of explained that in your story
before where you thought if you just
went along with things that kind of
kept your head down is yeah that's
that's how you felt
yeah they will come for you i mean these
i you can't it's it's getting to a point
where you are it's compelled
i mean look at the clark v democracy
that's about compelled speech
this is now we are now not talking about
like suppression of speech we're talking
about they're
you're going to be asked to say things
that you do not necessarily believe in
as a continued condition of your
employment or you're getting a good
grade
you're going to lose your job unless you
bend the knee so if you would rather
live on your knees
than then then fight on your feet well
then so be it that's what you deserve
and it's what you want and far be it for
me to criticize
no you should criticize because that
lends to the problem it exacerbates the
problem don't do it
listen i'm not here to recreate the
environment they've created
they want to create this environment
where they terrify you into dropping to
your knees
i don't want to create an environment
where you're terrified of my side
i'm going to tell you this you do your
thing if you do right i've got your back
but if you want to live on your knees
i'm not going to criticize you or
pressure you i mean no
i will i'll criticize you i'll criticize
you but i'm not going to create the same
environment where you are not welcome
if you want to live in this world where
you are at the behest of the woke cult
with no
real ideology just strange do as the
tribe says or else
that's up to you you're welcome to come
on the show you want to taste it yeah
if you want to taste it and then come
tell your personal story about how bad
it sucked go for it but don't do it
get up off your feet i think it's very
simple off your knees i
i grew up i grew up in chicago off your
toes off your job
i i grew up super far left i was a
skateboarder i was an anarchist i was in
all the punk rock music
and then like i i thought the system i
hated the system i had been
i had been messed with by cops before so
i was all just like cops are corrupt the
system is broken
this is you know it's terrible the war
machine and then i got older and
realized
there's nuance and ways to deal about
deal with these problems but having
grown
up kind of in not necessarily the gutter
but in a sense
you know guttery conditions i've also
been homeless a couple times there's
nothing anyone can take from me
i don't care you have nothing over me oh
you can take my job away
so what what's the worst case scenario
been there done that i'm not worried
about it
and so i'm free to speak my mind
i'm not scared but there are a lot of
people who are scared because they're
going to lose everything
well also because there's that fire you
know this fear it's not just about
losing your job it's about
literally being cast out of your herd
and i think that's partially
tim smarty i think partially that's why
this ideology is so effective it hooks
into this
that's a primal fear like getting past
that you're gonna get eaten by
creatures we survive with cooperation so
when you're out on your own you are in a
very risky position
but together we're strong the threat is
you will be excised well let me tell
everybody who's listening
there's very clearly an infrastructure
built where you will survive
opposing the cult of wokeness we're all
here
we're having a good time in fact i gotta
tell you i'm doing all right for myself
i love when they try claiming grifter
right i'm sure they call you a grifter
because you raised all this money
yes what's easier losing your job
freaking out your friends becoming a
social pariah in your in your industry
and your community or going along
pushing the narrative and just milking
it for all it's worth
what's safer being a woke neo-liberal
leftist promoting joe biden and the
democrat message
to make money on the platforms that will
you have no risk of being banned for
or challenging the system and facing
real risk of getting
your shows deleted every single day or
getting fired from your job
and crossing your fingers that there
will be people who agree with you to
donate to your gofundme
they call you a grifter yet at the same
time they do literally the same thing
plus they have institutional support
not only do these woke leftists who try
and pull some bs at schools
they've they've raised eighty thousand
dollars in several instances they've
rated
raised tens of thousands of dollars they
then get propped up by magazines by
newspapers
these same people can appear on jimmy
kimmel and these late-night shows
they're not going to do that for you
tucker carlson will and then people will
get freaked out so which is easier
you want to talk about the real grift
it's the youtubers who are
on the left it's the youtubers who tow
the the party is the party line in the
establishment line knowing
they will never get banned for this and
have nothing to worry about and can milk
it for all it's worth even when they put
out fake news
the real risk they call it the grift
they're only saying that because
they want to stop you dead in your
tracks like breitbart said now
speaking out against the establishment
is as risky as you can get
because we know people get banned they
get shut down i mean gofundme froze
your account for for an administrative
reason mind you
but gofundme has deleted the the the
fundraisers for
many conservatives it's not it's not
it's
not a grift yeah it's interesting though
how it gets framed
you're talking about these other
youtubers these social justice warriors
they frame it as if they're counter
culture
they're they're fighting against the
power
you know and it's like they don't i
don't know if
it's hard for me to believe that they
don't understand that they are part of
the power that this
is the establishment they are literally
the power thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you